[Music]
impossible as it sounds
this is a carryover of something that
should have been dead
65 million years ago uh
listen to yourself
you are a distinguished physicist
engineer
lawyer
and you were sitting here
telling me that there's a dinosaur in
this lake not quite i'm saying there's a
remnant there was a remnant of one at
least in 1975.
absolutely telling you that that was 60
minutes scott pelley interviewing late
mit scientist bob reins back in 2001
about his belief in the loch ness
monster scotland's most famous and
enduring mystery that's what you
actually saw
yes
how big was it
well it's back in the news again
thanks to a discovery made thousands of
miles away
nessie as she's known has been part of
scottish folklore for centuries becoming
a worldwide sensation in 1933 after a
series of alleged sightings and
photographs looking for a plausible
explanation some claimed she was the
descendant of the plesiosaur a
long-necked aquatic dinosaur and that
idea just became a bit more plausible
paleontologists working in morocco's
sahara desert found evidence that
plesiosaurs not only lived in oceans and
seas but in fresh water too we found
some plesiosaurs in an ancient riverbed
which was a little surprising they're in
a freshwater environment and this is a
group that was thought to be mostly
marine and it indicates this group was
able to come specialize to exploit
freshwater environments nick longrich is
a paleontologist at england's bath
university and the lead author of a
report on the fossil find we found a lot
of different plesiosaur fossils in this
freshwater deposit we found juveniles we
found adults we found bones we found
teeth that they lost they shed their
teeth kinda like sharks so we found a
lot of fossils suggesting these things
were up there routinely and probably
spent much if not all of their lives in
fresh water
despite the discovery most scientists
still doubt that an ancient dinosaur
could have survived in the dark and
frigid waters of loch ness which was
only formed 10 000 years ago during the
ice age
but that likely won't convince the true
believers including the thousands of
camera toting tourists who line the lock
every year looking to capture the
creature and prove the legend is real 66
million years ago the asteroid hits all
these things go extinct including the
plesiosaurs as a scientist i can never
say anything is impossible all
hypotheses are on the table in some
level until they're proven false we
could find the loch ness sponsor
tomorrow it could be a plesiosaur i
think that is however extremely unlikely
given the evidence we have at this point
but there's a chance there's a dude
there's a chance isn't that fascinating
i know it is the pictures are not
convincing but i mean the people who
who claim to have seen right this
creature
they they seem to be pretty adamant
about it and now with the teeth and the
fossils and the things that you found
saying okay well if plesiosaurs were
fresh water
animals that are dinosaurs then what
i believe it's possible anything's
possible